hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today we're gonna be talking
about something different a game that's
been on my radar since the game Ward's
like many others and it that is going to
be new world the new MMO game designed
by Amazon Game Studios so like I said
this is a new MMO IP it's PvP and PvE
content and they on their Twitter
account the official New World Twitter
they talked about that somewhere during
the week they were going to release a
blog post slash a video detailing all
the stuff that they were talking about
with PvP how it's changing and other
things of that nature and a lot of
people were intrigued because if you
played mmo's in the past you understand
that PvE content is really nice but it's
really that end game player versus
player interaction fighting style that's
going to solidify the game and keep you
entertained because there's only so many
times that you can grind the same boss
in the same enemy before you a either
have all this stuff within the game or
it just gets super super boring within
the video one of the main heads and
directors of the game was stating about
a few things they'd done they had
released an alpha way back in 2018 of
October that ended somewhere in June of
2019 kind of detailing what was going on
how do players interact how did they
interact with the players the behaviors
anything that players did and they gave
them all the freedom to do so and play
as if it was the normal game they
noticed a lot of players were focusing
on PvP content fighting other players
and really enjoying that system but they
feel like that they needed more solo
evil stuff more PvE content to keep them
kind of going so during the Alpha they
are making many many changes like adding
different sources of loot adding more
different things to keep the players
entertained and seeing how that would
change their outcome and it was somewhat
well-received but one of the issues that
they noticed when they were playing PvP
is that they had an open combat system
basically you were able to be attacked
at any time at any point and it didn't
matter who was there so if you're
chopping down some tree running through
a forest you might get your ass ambushed
and you're dead and out for the count so
during this alpha they made a few
changes one of them being the way that
PvP works now so eventually you can join
a faction within the game and you can
participate in Wars which we'll get into
a little bit later but also one of the
things when you get to a higher level is
the ability to opt into PvP to make it
that open-world I can die whenever I
want kind of thing but for new players
this would more be of the opting out so
that you can kind of get to the
game understand the mechanics and then
maybe opt in later the problem with
opting in and opting out is sometimes
people don't want to do that there's
gonna be those guys that solo the game
and kind of plan their lonesome don't
opt into PvP and just do all the PvE
content on their own
one of the main Directors in the video
head stated that you can actually play
PvE throughout the entire game and never
touch player versus player content but
he stated that it's probably most likely
going to happen where players are going
to get more comfortable with the game
feel a lot better about themselves get a
lot more gear and then hop into that
player versus player interaction if you
never want a PvP you can absolutely
avoid it the only issue is that it's not
mandatory and it's a choice some players
like I had stated before don't need to
as he clearly states who can play this
game through PvP my only problem with
this is that he seems to be banking on
the fact that players will eventually do
it but sometimes players don't end up
doing PvP at all I mean there's players
that have played elder scrolls online
who have never touched PvP at all and
just do that regular solo Bowl content
as much as they can
another thing that was stated was about
the player to player interaction like we
have talked about throughout this entire
video and that's literally the main
point but how does it work right you're
just gonna ambush a dude what do you get
out of it and they stated that in the
Alpha if you were to kill somebody you
could be able to take all of their [ __ ]
like this is some game of tarkoff or
rust but the community as they were
playing found that these rewards were a
bit too harsh and a bit dampening yeah I
mean you spend 20 minutes 30 minutes
doing whatever you need to do getting
that final piece of gear just to get
slain by some dude in the back and he
takes it I can understand that but I
also kind of think this is a nice system
to always be on your back and you know
always watching and making sure and then
also that gives the players incentives
to maybe team up with a group or a
faction to do other things out in the
world with so the new system that they
had talked about with something
time-based and I'm really not sure what
that means that they didn't really go
into full detail on what the time-based
thing means the first thing I thought of
was minecraft when you die you have like
a 5 to 10 minute timer before your loot
D spawns I don't know if that's the
actual case there but if that is the
case I can kind of understand where
that's nice but depending on how far you
are or where you spawn or how the
spawning even works in the game that
could be a really simple thing to do
like if you
if you die out of right out of town walk
back into town spawn in it walk two feet
grab your stuff and act like nothing
happened on the positive though players
will be getting rewards if you do opt
into PvP you'd like bonus XP and
additional rewards but they haven't
stated what those rewards are but the
systems they had in the very beginning
of the Alpha was a system called
criminal intent if you were marked as a
criminal and you died as a criminal you
would get your loot taken but if you
killed somebody as a criminal you could
take what was ever in their inventory
but any armor or weapons they had
equipped would stay with them but it
would lose their ability meaning they'd
have to repair it which I don't actually
mind that as a system besides the one on
one or maybe one on two type of PvP
content we also have these giant faction
wars that can spawn within the faction
war kind of area closed off from the
game or within the actual game itself in
open world they stated that in a closed
scenario you fight an a faction vs.
faction basis it's a 50 B 50 fight the
defending team has to defend a certain
area of land whether it's a castle or
whatever it happens to be
well the attacking team does what you
would think and has to go charge that
castle and end up trying to take it down
while killing the other 50 players which
honestly sounds really nice the only
issue is that like the developer stated
this is an opt-in kind of thing and you
don't need to actually do this to
progress very far in the game this is an
optional route you can take large scale
battles like these can happen in the
open world area once again you do have
to opt in for that PvP aspect and you
also have to get a group together so if
some faction is beef and wheat your
faction you have to set it up like this
is some kind of RSVP day you're most
likely not gonna run into ten guys
versus your ten guys and it's not gonna
it's probably not going to happen as
much now I stated that we had that
criminal system which was in the Alpha
and the only problem as the developer
had stated is now that they have this
opt-in kind of scenario for the full
game and not what it was with the
criminal system in the Alpha the
criminal system no longer exists and it
is fully opt-in if you die you get your
stuff gone like all that type of stuff
so as much as I really kind of enjoyed
this criminal system it won't be in the
game they also mentioned how this
faction war kind of system works and if
you're a big fan of Elder Scrolls online
if you've been playing since the
beginning or whatever it happens to be
this is going to be kind of a close to
home kind of situation with territories
on screen you're going to be seeing
a demo mock-up of a picture I found on
Google images of eso PvP stuff you're
gonna be seeing a lots of blues reds and
yellows if you're an ESO employer you
already know this but for the people
that don't understand you fight for
these little towers that are gonna be on
your screen now you fight for those
towers and once you cut once you claim
those that group owns that Tower
and you can push people to the ends of
their line right to their border if you
wanted to you cut off spawns depending
on which one you go to but to capture
those 90% of the time you're going to be
in some type of group fight because
there's always going to be people
stationed at those towers and that as
similar house territories are going to
be working within new world as well and
personally as a big fan of ESO even
though I haven't played in a very long
time I thoroughly did enjoy this combat
and I thought it was very nice although
my only issue with New Worlds is like I
said it's opt-in and it's also an
optional thing that you don't have to do
so let's hope that it does provide and
give some incentive to players to
continue playing this and then to send
it off they last talked about PvE and
went back to that kind of content
because what we talked about PvP you
know we have to talk about just about
all the loads of content coming one of
the things happening with PvE is that
there isn't going to be many raids or
dungeons and if there is there's going
to be very small amounts I actually
don't even think that they'll have them
on launch I could have misinterpreted
that statement but they are gonna be
having world bosses and other bosses
that are going to require some players
and extra people to fight but they're
not going to have as many on launch they
kind of want to see where the player
behavior goes and what the players want
it's like let's say later down the line
two weeks into the game people are
saying no we need raids we need dungeons
we need all that type of content now
then they're like okay we should
definitely focus on a more PvE section
for this newest update for all the post
wasn't too bad but a lot of players are
feeling very disappointed as you can
tell by the like to dislike ratio on
this video and the player comments the
one biggest thing a lot of people talked
about was PvP servers now this is
actually not a bad idea having an entire
server dedicated to PvP so that there is
no opt-in and opt-out system you can
just hop into a world and it's
automatically I'm gonna get killed or
I'm gonna kill somebody or I don't want
to do that and I want to co kind of
explore the the lands of new world and
stuff judging from the comments a lot of
people are not really in the best mood
about this game not having PvP servers
although of course this could change the
betas not even out yet that
add these before launch so we'll have to
see especially for the beta where we can
finally get a lot more gameplay of our
own and kind of see what's going on if
I'm allowed to record stuff during the
beta I will most definitely be recording
the PvP stuff to let you guys know
what's going on with that if there's
servers etc all that stuff so yeah let
me know what you guys think about the
stuff in the comments below do you think
it was a good idea that they're going
for a more PvE style but maybe at the
expense of more player versus player
content are you super big on the player
versus player content or maybe just kind
of like to you know take a stroll every
couple hours you know do a little PvE
stuff and just kind of go on your way
let me know what you guys think about
this stuff in the comments below as
always I'll be covering this game in the
very future of course when the beta
comes out when the full game comes out
all that stuff to keep you guys up to
date on what's going on with new world
so yeah as always like the video if you
do enjoy subscribe for free new and with
that take care guys have a great stir
day let me know what you guys think
about this stuff in the comments below
have a good rest of your day
[Music]
you